Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin's
intense makeout in them streets Nicki
Minaj slays the BT Awards with her
jaw-dropping performance and cardi B it
offset secretly married everybody this
is the daily Denny I'm Denny direct oh I
could talk about how the weekend flew by
what the heck but it was a busy one we
had the BT Awards and Radio Disney Music
Awards and let's not forget all the
pride festivities even Lady Gaga hit the
streets in New York to celebrate and I
gotta say NYC pride look lint there
really was a celebration of love in all
forms this weekend just ask Justin
Bieber and Haley Baldwin these two have
until now kept their rumored romance
under wraps and now they can't keep
their hands off each other
check this out look at the Biebs Justin
Haley was snapped in the middle of a
very intent and very public makeout
session in a Big Apple on Friday I mean
talk about a steamy embrace y'all last
week the pair was also spotted leaving a
Cipriani restaurant in Soho hand-in-hand
after a cozy dinner date let me remind
you the pair dated for a hot minute in
2015 and have been seen together more
and more in recent weeks in 2016 Baldwin
even gushed to ET about Bieber her
then-boyfriend he's really funny we have
a good time together he's just really
sweet he's a good kid it's a good heart
and I love him Bieber is like a damn
relationship boomerang his ex is just
always find a way back to his arms I
tell ya well we're not here for a long
time we're here for a good time right
Biebs right meanwhile the stars hit the
black carpet for the ve T Awards
yesterday and it was a huge night for a
lot of people but I gotta start with my
girl Janelle Monae who shared her pride
in the form of this epic rainbow tulle
dress she did that you know Janelle
revealed in April that she is pansexual
but it was all about girl power on the
bTW stage where she proved once again
she is a creative force to be reckoned
with
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I stand for Janelle Monae but you know
who else did not come to play last night
no surprise here but Miss Nicki Minaj
the rapper slayed and have everybody
talking about her sexy one-two punch
or should I say judo chop of chun-li and
rich sex
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gonna be architect that transfer
[Music]
his book enhance though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my eyes oh my god Nicki do you guys spot
the rainbow coloring and Nicky's hair
I'm sensing a theme this weekend and I'm
here for it
all right of course it wouldn't be an
award show without a head scratching
moment like this one for rapper offset
that had many fans wondering did he and
cardi B secretly get married
thank God I thank my wife you should
thank yours that way well the cat is out
of the bag because cardi B just
confirmed via Instagram today that she
is indeed married she says there are so
many moments that I share with the world
and then there are moments that I want
to keep for myself getting married was
one of those moments well congrats the
cardi B and off set and as she told her
fans
now you guys she didn't have a child out
of wedlock put that to rest all right
speaking of free things to rest I'm
switching gears now because it was also
a big weekend for Kelly Clarkson she was
the big hero at the Radio Disney awards
receiving the icon award but it was on
the red carpet where she posed for a
very rare photo with Carrie Underwood
check this out
two American auto winners in the house
and apparently Kelly was hoping this
would squash any rumors of a feud with
care everybody always threats have hit
me and Carrie against each other didn't
when I saw her I was like you know what
let's just end this right now and get a
picture together cuz we never in the
same place and like it never happened
people always try and put it together
like we're like enemies I'm like really
know each other there will have to be
enemies
so like anyway I went to get a picture
and then everybody lost their mind what
is it like to kind of have to American
Idol winners you and Terry both here
tonight and being honored and Maddie
Pope whose present he knew you both are
right yeah it's cool it's like pasta in
prison I love it yeah have you ever met
before I saw that you actually Instagram
thanking her for sending you some
athletic wear yeah her Kelly oh it's
really really rad she but how they
presented it was like to Lori
ain't nobody got time for your feud
rumors you won't start none won't be
none
all right guys we have plenty more from
the RDMA s including Ludacris meeting
yodeling kid
Mason Ramsey it's really cute and you
guys will love it all right I'll be back
tomorrow with another daily Denny until
then hit subscribe and make sure you
see this playlist I goodbye